if you're following us at aj+ then
you've seen what we've been cooking up
in our labs every day we bring you
videos that spark debate and empower the
voiceless and we're only just getting
started so I bet you want in on the
action well guess what we want you to
we're introducing the brand-new aj+
fellowship which means you get to join
us for a year and you help us build a j+
as we share it with the world it's going
to be awesome and this is our color for
applicants we're looking for six
individuals from six regions around the
world to make up our first class of a
JBoss fellows you'll have to be a social
media ninja and also a complete news
junkie you also have to be on top of all
those various conversations happening in
your region that are not hitting the
headlines yes you will be paid and if
you're lucky you'll get a hoodie so
think you got what it takes if so read
up more at aj+ net / fellows